so people say to me bill know what can I
do about climate change and these days I
acknowledge that not wasting water
bottles not throwing newspapers away
recycle them that's all good and
important driving less driving smaller
car or more efficient cars electric car
but the main thing we can all do about
climate change right now is talk about
it we just talk about climate change and
raise awareness of it then the world's
biggest economy the United States might
lead the world in addressing climate
change creating sources of renewable
energy wind and solar most notably tidal
energy then we could export that
technologies in a technology and export
those technologies and change the world
so if I since I believe that talking
about it's really important I talk about
it all the time and that that's the more
you think about it everybody
ninety-seven percent of the world's
scientists not ninety-seven percent of
some Institute that somebody started in
a remote part of the world and is making
releasing press releases ninety-seven
percent of the scientists in the world
are very concerned about climate change
and you can look at the graphs you can
study this stuff for yourself if nothing
else do this wherever you live get
access to the coldest temperature of the
lat year for the last century unless you
live inside just very few places you
will see the coldest temperature where
you live has steadily increased there'll
be some dips will be some ups but
overall you'll find it up good and
that's just one that almost everybody
who has internet access can get those
data they're available and just just
look at that one thing and you'll see
the world's getting warmer everybody the
oceans getting warmer so it's getting
bigger and those people are going to get
displaced and we're going to have to
change our economy and where we do
business we're going to be abandoning
hectares acres and acres of asphalt
roadway
is copper plumbing we're going to be
abandoning all that and it's going to be
expensive so the sooner we get to work
the better